so you have the same faith and the same
B the same faith and the same
F go
back this hand's going to be in spir
this hand's going to be
our same same around and resp
spiral
out
just inal
spir
inward
out
outward
in
here and lower his head's going to be
there
lower under
it around your head Bo here on the back
it so that lowering
now like go okay when I lower it drops
this
hand okay
to pin that inside
foot lower this on my head
lower lift it up over your head and
pull going to hit the
Box
we just look at the Y hand you see it's
going like
this
here turn tight
under when you make it go over his
head there's no weight on his body
he's got his balance you
see no don't do that you can feel where
the torque is torque then slightly off
you get it feel the
torque and then as I go up it'll come
off off at the top I know you it looks
like he's bouncing over go slow resist
to stay in place
no see I keep that going inside and then
I get out of the
way resist pull pull pull pull and no
this way see if feel high I have your
Center okay and then watch as it goes up
you can push down now okay I
turn duck
out so you're constantly feeling his
Center and watch the other hand okay
here let go we'll focus on this hand
okay same thing so here you see the
center don't go
here
W so if you know what to feel for you
you're not going to take it off
it's off it's off right
there and this is off right here this
has to keep it going and drop his
weight so just feel his
body
no you feel how you you're
there inside under drop
weight feel what you want him to
do then you always have it and now you
can buide
it you're
not
[Music]
accelerating have a center have a center
you feel
that
acceleration Center
[Music]
Center
okay try
it
okay good let's do it again and I want
you to pay attention to how straight she
actually is in that b chain you can that
you turn yourself
we'll all be conscious of
that you
see so we're not really throwing her
okay and let's now pay attention how
you're lifting her hand over her head do
you see you're Shing it over her head
okay now pay attention how when you do
that all the rest that we just noted
that's what
happens
okay you see that she's going to stand
up straight cuz I'm going to leave the
all right so now let's pay attention to
the other hand and see if we're actually
using it at all do you see just left it
there okay so when you go like this and
you're trying to get that over there
see okay stay there then look at your
posture now okay all right now here's
where I roll this hand watch I'm not
going to pick this up because it's
already above your head I just go
here and did you notice I not straight
up okay you can feel
it you're pregnant I'm not going to slam
you but you can feel it okay so here and
start moving your Center you see
backwards there's that
part it's here and
then this way you
see
okay now pay
attention
okay moving you around you see you feel
it okay under I go there's the same
thing I now do the our spiral
here okay relax I'll get you there and I
want you to feel how right
there do it again come back around do it
again start over Virginia we can
boom
boom you feel your body
BL
okay feel your body yes so at the
moment when you
turn still have you then I let you go
cuz you can't do the fall okay it's not
that you don't have you I turn you and
then I don't have
you then I have to
accelerate if you some telltale signs is
he never gets up you see he never gets
up he's not up here
straight he's never in that
posture you're tilting
him you see okay you guys see that
okay never gets
up that's what that Center connection is
what you're
dropping
okay okay so let's look at the Y hand as
he's coming around this hand right here
so we'll just look at that bottom hand
okay so as you grab it I want you to let
go of this one so no one gets distracted
okay boom goes boom and
then
boom
and in
out in
out this is the shape of it don't I'm
not just showing that there's a inward
because inward always proceedes outward
outward always proceeds Inward and then
the
roll this
way
work for those who don't know
K is the inward
spiral and the outward spiral you have e
your right so he comes
around boom
[Music]
goom okay let's get that shape that
that's not the timing the those
movements are too long for what we're
going to do but that is the shape okay
all right let's try that we're going to
keep with the movement but you can start
shaking them if you get too big it's
going to be a bigger stepping stone to
the technique okay so again you come
comes around and
elbow
elbow okay comes
around
boom all right and to that we add the CH
drop so
around here's where I
drop
around boom
here and just
pull this the drop we want the drop have
the arm
movement
boom boom drop just like when I drop
everything I want to put it on my Center
Line oh that's when I drop okay don't
have it over here drop here don't have
it over there drop going have it over
here and
Drop Pop
Mo right
here okay try
watch okay so as it goes here
if I step it's not under my Center
you're going to have to pull
[Music]
it what I'm going to
do is it moves do you see there it is
Dro you don't want to drag across your
body because your AR deltoid is going to
be in the
technique one dud I brought it to my
Cent I'm as much over it as it is under
me you guys see that okay so this would
be
incorrect okay just go boom boom drop
okay try to so on the throw you I know
you have inward here right right so go
again go slow so I can talk do you see
here Al for Al into inward
okay inward into outward you see okay
see all right and now it's going to go
outward into inward okay so stay stay
where you are and my weight I put my
weight on that hand this the
throw not pulling him okay just
like K is not me pushing him come back K
is me
dropping got it okay so I drop the hand
we do it again outward inward inward
outward outward and now you have your
inward on this hand stay where you are
okay inward over here up to shoulder
line You Feel
[Music]
It
Center
okay try
that keep
going
we're not
not okay so okay well what am I training
what should I train for you get it so
right now you you're just kind of pain
them
thing see I don't really you turn
yourself you get it and so I know that I
know that you know it okay so I think
you're better off if you're like Center
you see you feel that okay she
goes you
see I feel her body there it
is you're going to get way more out of
that like I'm actually controlling your
body you don't have to do anything for
me right you get it you I train that way
instead versus like I want him I want
her to look like
him it
doesn't because there's no control of
the center you get it okay and that's
what they're trying to do they're trying
yeah they're doing this throw but
they're trying to
get okay does that make
sense so as you comeing around and you
pay attention there's his
face you see so you can't be nice and
throw just like we were throwing I step
here
but we know there's an X powder so as he
comes around I go
in
okay one Mo instead of stepping out and
doing a but what in essence is x pattern
is going that way so it's
very uh is it
obuse to the right
angle okay you go perpendicular
then you're in a Hell boom and in
this okay you guys stay up to and you
guys play with that okay
right
[Music]
there
for